element 113 is again and labeled with
this new systematic rent method for the
artificial elements so you have own own
trium or it might be a nun trium I don't
know which stands for 113 and you might
actually ask why should anybody want to
make a few atoms of these artificial
elements and I think the answer
I don't know definitely is that there
have been predictions that although the
elements at this part of the periodic
table are very unstable that there may
that heavier elements be one or two
elements which are surprisingly stable
might last for very much longer
they're called islands of stability that
they'd been predicted and so people are
working systematically to see whether in
fact there one or two elements that are
really quite stable even though they're
super heavy and when I was a young
researcher in the 1970s somebody I can't
remember who it was got very excited
because they thought in remnants of very
ancient mineral mica it's a sort of
mineral that comes in layers that they
found some strange patterns which they
thought was indication of super-heavy
elements decaying perhaps as heavy as
element 164 enormous ly heavier than
anything that anybody's ever been able
to create in the lab it turned out not
to be as exciting as they thought and
there was some other completely
different explanation but it is testing
theories and things like that that
really move science forward